The Kepler space telescope discovered something very strange.
And there're suspicions that could be a sign of alien intelligence.
Scientists aren't saying it's aliens, but, come on!
It's totally aliens!
Hey everyone tracy here for d news with astronomer
Aaron white from the California Academy
of Sciences hi Aaron I'm gonna get
excited about aliens you've probably
heard this week about a super weird
discovery from the Kepler space
telescope there might be aliens around a
distant star KIC 846 2852 or at least
that's how it's being reported
yeah there's a lot of excitement around
the story but we've got to keep ourselves
grounded essentially the Kepler space
telescope has a specific mission we're
looking for planets around distant stars
Kepler spotted something unusual and that
has been blown up by the media to huge
proportions we're not saying it's aliens
but maybe aliens. Let me reiterate astronomers are
not saying its aliens, they're just not
ruling out aliens as a possibility
right? So kepler's mission is to look for
transiting planets around other stars. We've
talked about these on Dnews before, Kepler
looks at a star and if a planet passes
between the star and our point of view
we'd see a dimming lights so think about
it this way normal starlight and the
planet start passing slightly dim more dim
slightly brighter back to normal cause
the planet's moved away that's
predictable at regular and it's easy to
spot a planet that way. Right exactly
that's called the transit it's an easy
way to detect planets around other stars, now just keep in mind a normal run of
the mill a giant planet like jupiter, which by
the way is about a hundred and twenty
two times larger than the earth, will only
dim a star by about 1% when we see this
transit the crazy thing about this story
is that KIC 8 462 8528 is showing dips in
the ballpark of 20% that, is insane. So this could mean, right Aaron,
that something huge is blocking the stars light
over on TestTube+ Dr Ian O'Neill
astrophysicist and I talked about how a
sufficiently advanced civilization might
build a Dyson Sphere around a sun! We're
talking about a Dyson spheres come'on! Dyson spheres! So a Dyson Sphere
is essentially a huge collection of
space-based solar panels that gathers up
light from its host star in it converts
it into usable energy, any civilization
that could build one of these things
would get them access to an enormous
power source but as a side effect it
would block the star's light from
a distant viewers perspective,
like maybe us. So a Dyson sphere might
explain the observations of KIC whatever
if your goal is to show other
civilizations of your existence putting
a beacon like a big artificial thing
around your star would definitely do it. So
what we're seeing could be explained by
alien intelligence looking to make its
presence known to other intelligent
beings, but to be honest it could also be
a lot of other things.
Party pooper.
But that's why astronomers have always got to be careful about making any claims
about aliens remember aliens or not this
is still a pretty unprecedented finding
the reason that were even at this point
of mentioning aliens is that so far the
explanations for this huge dimming have
come up pretty short. Good ol' KIC 84
whatever it is that's an f3 type star
its on its main sequence basically this
means that the star isn't too old it
isn't too young it's a little harder
than our star which tells us that any
dust clouds left over from its formation
or particles blown off to the end of the
star's life are unlikely sources for
this dimming we're seeing. Absolutely, KIC
whatever also rotate slightly faster
than once per earth day this is way faster
than the observed dims that we're seeing
meaning star spots which are sun spots
but just but on stars over there on this
star surface cannot be responsible one
of their main guess is that some sort of
the collision within the system left
debris cloud. It could be asteroids
impacting each other, it could be planets
colliding, but even that doesn't fully
explain this dimming factor normally dust
from collisions would heat up and then
glow with infrared light which we would
then be able to detect using
ground-based follow-up surveys and they
did not detect any IR aliens Aaron say yes!? Uh, still unlikely I'm sorry instead
the best explanation is actually
commets. Commets?
yeah commets so it turns out that of
commets are in a distant orbit around
the star and they were recently
perturbed and knocked into the system
they could have bashed together they
would leave an abscure debris cloud
that could explain what we're seying commets are in
white orbit so any debris would move in
and out of our line of sight so it's
possible that when they did these
follow-up surveys looking for the ir
missions they could have just missed
that debris cloud and therefore wouldn't
have seen the infrared left behind.
This is actually the most likely scientific
solution that been offered so far, but it
would have to be a pretty incredible
coincidence that out of the billions of
years the star has yet to live this
event happened in the four year time
span that Kepler was looking at it
seriously the odds are literally
astronomical
astronomical it's important to stress
here that all this talk of Dyson spheres
an alien it's it's a far-flung idea A.K.A.
as we sometimes say. I hear that you have a saying. Do you want to say it?
"More research is needed"
Remember, twenty years ago we just
detected the first batch of exoplanets
like ever exoplanet research is still in its
infancy the most likely solution is that
there are some natural phenomenon that
we haven't observed, or we haven't thought
of yet and that's what we're saying look
astronomers are not saying it's aliens
and they're not saying it's not aliens
it's like they're saying it's not not
aliens but we don't know what it is. Yeah,
so here's the thing is that finding life
beyond Earth is probably the biggest and
most profound discovery that science
could make
so we need to be absolutely sure that we
exhaust every other possible explanation
before you make that claim that aliens
are responsible so you know whenever you
ask an astronomer is it aliens? the respond
with no of course not there's more
plausible explanations don't even think
about it but there's always that little
bit in the background minds that says well maybe. What do you guys think about this
discovery? is the media blowing it out of
proportion! or is this a conspiracy cover
up of X-File-ien proportions! Luckily
scientists have explored the idea of
what alien life might actually look like
if we were to come across it and Amy as
wages those alien intelligence in this
video here
the arsenic became a building block for any strength cell when this news came out it was massively
exciting for the astrobiology and space
world but the discovery was eventually debugged
so thanks for watching everybody make
sure you subscribe so you get all of our
videos and Aaran if they have follow-up
questions about aliens I hear they can
find you on Twitter at Astro what? Astro W UT
it's alien so right I mean I can't say yes
just between you and me aliens? In my heart I want it.